foreign
in Fort Wayne listen to Kelly just
producing the show like like a like a
producer what's up Bethany
hey how's it going good how are you
going oh yeah
oh man what's up
um well I am calling because
um my husband and I have well mostly me
I've had issues with intimacy like since
we've been writers made for almost five
years and it's just like kind of a cycle
um I get I work really hard and it's
going good for a month or two and then
life happens and there's something big
happens and then I have to start all
over again afterwards and I'm kind of
sick of it I want to know how to end the
cycle yeah no kidding so
man a couple things you said are
heartbreaking and this is me not at you
but me with you
um
so hey I want to make sure we're we're
saying the same things when you talk
about intimacy you're talking about
having sex and you're talking about just
the whole environment around sex in your
house
um I guess
or tell me I'm wrong what do you mean by
intimacy
um yeah mostly fixed okay okay
um and you say it's a it's a cycle what
is tell me more about that and um talk
directly into your phone I can uh having
a little bit of trouble hearing you
um what do you mean when you say cycle
well I
well like before we got married I'd been
almost engaged with somebody else and
they're
had been some boundary issues there and
it took me a while to get over those and
actually
get to wear physical
into touch and other things were
kind of enjoyable
and then when you say boundary issues
were you sexually assaulted
um not necessarily assaulted but like I
I never verbally said no and it was
nothing more than like french kissing
but I didn't want it and he didn't
respond to any physical cues that I was
sending
so that was your first time you were in
a situation where you felt out of
control of your own body
yes yes okay all right and did you have
abuse in your in your own personal
perspect when you were a kid
no okay all right so fast forward to now
then you get married and
[Music]
it's tell me about this cycle
so that took me a lot of work through my
husband is great he one of the reasons
why I fell in love with him so fast is
because he always asks before everything
he's a consent guy
oh yeah he's fantastic yeah
um
but I worked through all those issues I
read a lot of books I went to some
therapy I did some ambr
and
it got a lot better and then like I
can't remember what happened but I'd
have a season of depression and then
like something else would crop up that
affected intimacy negatively for me and
it's just like every time
I'd get good at it then something would
happen
like we'd have to move or I'd have a kid
and into the pause after you have a kid
and it'd take me forever to get back
into it and I'd have to work through
different things but I have to work all
over again
some of what you're describing is normal
life
yeah like you have a kid and then
everything's a disaster
all across I mean everything's a
disaster right meal time is a disaster
sex is a disaster you're like your body
is not your own right I mean so there's
there that adjustment period is natural
can I ask you a question and tell me I'm
if I'm off base okay
okay
does somebody tell you sex is really bad
foreign up
but
because your body sounds like it has a
response to it it's not a safe place
intimacy and connection in an ideal
world is a place where
you can go be fully yourself because
there's nowhere to hide right
yeah you've heard that like Let your
freak flag fly or that it's where you
literally have no clothes on in front of
somebody else right and there's nowhere
else to hide so I'm gonna be fully me
and everywhere else I have to perform I
have to perform at work I have to
perform at my in-laws house I got to
perform at my parents house I got to
perform with my kids at school
but behind closed doors with somebody
that like I am
I have I'm handing all my trust to
man we can get off the rails it's a
place of Safety and Security and for
your body it is not it's the opposite
where does that come from
[Music]
probably
it's just I don't know
being that vulnerable is really scary
why is that scary like why does your
body go go into neutral or go to shut
down when
um you're being vulnerable because that
would tell me that it doesn't only just
happen with sex and intimacy it happens
when your husband gets frustrated or
when you get mad or when you suffer a
loss or heartbreak your body does very
similar things is that right
yeah I think so okay
where did your body learn that the best
your best bet the best way to keep you
safe was to disappear
was to shut it down
not being good enough
who told you you weren't good enough
I don't think my family it but I mean
it's a really big family
probably myself honestly
sometimes our families tell us things
that
plant seeds within us that bloom later
on into really gnarly Thorn bushes that
make life really hard
and sometimes they plant No Seeds
so we look up and we're 25 or we're 30
and we have our own kids and there is
there's no fruit to drum on there's
nothing
and you can
absorb the story
that you're not even worth taught
telling a story to
and then that becomes the story you tell
yourself which is you're not enough oh
you're not gonna do this right or you're
gonna screw up or somebody else is going
to be disappointed and and and
then that guy who you love
is like hey want to do it
and your body goes into well I could
fail I could screw this up I could not
be enough for him I could fill in the
blank is that fair
yeah that's about right okay so here's
the challenge that I I'm hearing
there's two there's two con conflicting
things happening one is this depression
that's haunted you for a long time
and you're trying to heal it
episodically meaning I want to not feel
this particular way about a particular
thing
so it's kind of like your house is on
fire and every time the Smoke Gets In
Your particular room you turn on a fan
to blow the Smoke Out
and you're trying to figure out where
the Smoke's coming from so you can blow
the smoke out when really what we need
to do is put the fire out
you get what I'm saying
um
so the the EMDR is trauma-based and so
if that was around your previous
boyfriend taking advantage of you or not
not respecting your not responding to
your cues and then the resulting guilt
and shame all that stuff that comes from
feeling like your body is not your own
right when somebody steals out from you
um
EMDR is good for that moment the broader
conversation is sitting with a therapist
and a counselor and talking about the
generalized depression the bigger
picture my body has learned over time
your story doesn't matter you just need
to disappear and what we need to do is
over time teach that body nope
I've got needs I want to live a fun wild
Reckless exciting fun adventures of a
life because it's short and it goes by
really really fast and I want I want to
take everything from it I can I don't
want to give everything I can
um and so we're going to have to train
our body over time about that that's one
thing the other thing is just the
natural ups and downs of
being sexually intimate with somebody
over a long period of time
because there's babies and there's kids
and then there's work deadlines and
there's travel and then there's gain 30
pounds and then there's lost 40 pounds
and then there's wrinkles and then
there's remember that time and we used
to and now we don't need more and hey
you need to get testosterone and then
you need to get hormone therapy here but
there's just that the nature of it and
so what I am seeing across the country
is people shifting from a it's always
going to be on fire which isn't true to
it can be pretty hot talking about where
we are right now
and discovering hey you're into this
these days and you don't like this
anymore but you used to you don't like
this anymore and you want to try this
and have you thought about this and
that's a whole new level of intimacy
does that make sense
yeah so it's it's more about taking that
negativity that you feel surrounding
like I always had a baby we haven't it's
actually intimate in a long time I can
tell my husband's getting frustrated I'm
getting frustrated
but then my body tenses up and it goes
to war every time we try something and
it's uncomfortable and it's awkward it's
there that we're going to lean into that
and turn that into a moment of intimacy
in and of itself talking about it
laughing about it being silly about it
trying and then stopping and stopping
and trying we're gonna make that not
something to run and hide from but we're
going to make that the focus is that is
that is that ringing a bell
yeah okay I guess I have a question
we'll see this I've been through therapy
off and on for the last three years okay
and I only stopped when I feel
like like I can handle it and then I end
up having to go back how do I know when
like it's actually processed or do I
when your body doesn't take off on you
here here here's the the best way I can
explain it is
um
and you can read about this in the what
the book that I wrote my body responded
to economic crises it went to my it was
it acted as though when I saw a stock
ticker
and it had a red down arrow that the
stock market had lost money
my body would respond so over
dramatically it was as though somebody
had a hatchet and they were coming right
for me
and I remember I used to laugh
because I felt so out of control that a
couple of folks in a couple of banks
could take everything from me and I was
doing everything right in my home I felt
very very powerless does that make sense
then after counseling and working and
building a non-anxious life over the
last five to six to ten years
now we're in a recession heading towards
a deeper recession
my body hasn't taken off one time
meaning I've been frustrated and annoyed
and I'm heartbroken when I have to can't
buy bacon because the bacon prices are
so expensive and I got to choose between
bacon and bread
but I'm not spit staying up you know
until 2 A.M and then waking up again at
3 30 a.m on high alert all the time and
I can't talk to my kids I'm gonna I'm
like a taser
so I'm I'm Healed
I'm still worrying about it I'm still
frustrated by it but my body didn't go
to war and your body goes to shut down
and so it's you will know when you're
able when your husband says hey is
tonight a good sex night and you say
No not tonight but I would love to just
snuggle on the couch and hold hold you
tight for a while watch a show and when
you say those words your heart doesn't
start being really fast you're not
washed over in shame and frustration and
you're able to own your needs in that
moment
does that make sense
yeah so it happens like that for a while
again so what I want you to do is to
start really paying close attention when
you feel the cycle starting
what is different what is happening in
your life is your diet different are you
sleeping differently is your work
schedule or your husband's work
schedules your holiday coming up what is
it in the environment that starts to
kick that cycle up again
okay and I wanted I just want to be
really specific about track and that
kind of stuff even if it's going to get
a 99 cent Journal at Walmart
and then when it comes to sex and
intimacy I want you really to remember
this this is from Emily nagoski who if
you haven't uh I used to talk about the
book all the time I haven't in a while
um I recommend anybody who's having
conversations in their home
um like they're you know they're just a
married couple sitting there talking
about how they want to improve their sex
life or change their sex life there's a
book called come as you are that Emily
nigotsky wrote It's a masterpiece it's
incredible
um she was the first person I ever heard
so eloquently put
um outside of like nerd science journals
that there's no such thing as a sex
drive that's not real
that one person has more of a sex drive
and one person has less of a sex drive
and women's sex drive is just men's sex
drive light that's not true really
sexual desire is a series of of gas
pedals and breaks
and the goal is how can we work together
you and your husband
to
take off as many breaks as possible and
make the environment com more gas pedals
what that means is you're not just
focusing on what gets you off in the
bedroom or what you will or won't do in
the bedroom
it's more about how do we create a
context in our home in our life cycle so
that sex becomes a place that we want to
run to
that becomes a great escape not another
chore so what I mean by that is like is
it a clean home is it
um all the dishes are done is it flirty
notes throughout the day is it the oil
changed people who've had
um sexual trauma in their past often
smells are really intense and so maybe
it's no cologne or you got to brush your
teeth or it's need you to take a shower
first whatever the things are
um you don't feel good about your bodies
we're gonna dim the lights whatever the
thing is
or the things are we're going to create
a world where
sex can happen
not we're going to try to force uh we're
gonna try to force a game of baseball in
the middle of a winter storm no dude
let's create a world where baseball
sounds like it's a great idea does that
make sense
yeah yeah it does that can be a ton of
fun
for you and your husband to dream about
how do we create an environment that
that makes this that there's no breaks
and it's all gas pedals and then we're
going to put sex on the calendar how
many little kids do you have
three good gosh yes you have to put on
the calendar and let me tell you Bethany
nobody wants to do that nobody wants to
put sex on the calendar
I've never seen a Hollywood movie where
they're like hi hi
next Tuesday 4 15 p.m that has never
happened it's always like
Titanic and there's the car and then
there's like the handprint on the wall
and it's this passion and I'm gonna die
none of that's real
you got three little kids you got to put
on the calendar
and let's let's set a goal two times a
week
five times a week 17 times I'm just
kidding 17 times that's a lot if that's
safe that's how y'all roll that's how
you roll it's a lot but let's let's put
on the calendar and let's talk about it
let's talk about it
what would a world of nothing but gas
pedals in your home be and how can your
husband honor you and help make that
happen and for him what's a world of gas
pedals
not of just breaks of I don't like this
I don't like this no dude this what if
this was the way our life was
and then we were very intentional about
we're gonna have sex on these days at
these times and I'm gonna help with
bedtime I'm gonna help with this I'm
gonna help with this we're gonna create
this context and you're gonna do the
hard work of tracking this cycle so that
when it starts heading south you know
oh it's when I eat this and do this and
talk to them and don't take care of this
or it's when the weather gets like this
or it's possibly hormonal I need to work
with my doctor
that's where we're going to start
pulling that apart we're going to track
it and then we're going to teach our
body over time
that there's a different way to respond
to some of these stressors you're on the
right path Bethany and be really
gracious with yourself you got three
little ones
you're in Indiana it's cold be nice to
Bethany be nice to Bethany